are you doing sir how's it going man
good to see you nice to see you congrats
on the movie i thought you did a great
job thanks man
so is it true or not true that you only
agreed to do this movie when they added
a dancing scene because you wanted to
show more
after eurovision of your ability on the
dance floor
yeah i think i'm going to try and work
work some kind of dance into everything
from now on don't you think
why wouldn't you i mean you know it's
old it's classic hollywood
right 100
uh i am curious though how did this
script get to you because i don't
necessarily know if a lot of people
realize you can speak german
this is true i think um
they more people realize it in germany
um because i did a movie there about 13
years ago um it was a biopic of
hildegard knife and she her second
husband was an englishman who spoke
german
and uh so i i spoke a little german in
that movie um and i guess
somewhere in the german film industry
when they were looking uh to cast this
somebody said oh i think i think dan
stevens speaks german and uh you know
they were very actively looking for
a
non-german or a foreign actor who could
speak german for this role just to kind
of give it
a little
i don't know whether it's exotic this or
or just a kind of foreign quality
uh you know to to the role that that is
required to kind of both
you need someone who can get their head
around the
or their mouth around the language and
the sort of complex german but also to
have a slightly other
otherworldly thing about them
uh what was it though about this script
and story that said oh i totally want to
do this
i think it was just how kind of
simultaneously
sweet and funny
and kind of offbeat and weird but also
how kind of profound i've found it like
it's it's sometimes you read something
and it's kind of a bit glib and it's
it's funny but it sort of doesn't it has
no depth and then sometimes you read
things that are very earnest and serious
and are trying to tackle big issues but
there's no humor
and
this seemed to have a bit of both you
know and in a delightfully german kind
of way was able to tackle
really epic philosophical concepts in a
quite kind of
you know pleasant uh you know easy way
and um
and to inject you know some sort of
scrubable comedy humor
into something that's really tackling
questions about humanity and how we've
got here and where we're going and you
know i i found it just very very moving
on all on all levels um and this was
just from my first translation with my
old german dictionary dusted off the
shelf you know
this was before i even got to you know
talk to maria and um
you know was delighted to find that that
you know those were all the things that
she and and her partner yan who co-wrote
the screenplay
you know all those things they were
interested in in in kind of mining with
this with this script
uh this is an interesting film because
you have to deliver a particular type of
performance and you have to do it in
german so at any point were you like oh
i don't know if i can do this
um i mean
i like i like that feeling so if there's
a role where i'm like i don't know if i
can do this if the answer is
i think i can then it's the right kind
of challenge where i'm like if i answer
with like i don't i just don't think i
could do this like i don't i don't know
how i would pull this off then
it gets rejected or it doesn't happen
you know but if there's enough of it
like i've i felt the same way with
eurovision to be honest where i was like
i don't know if i can do this but i i
think i'm gonna try like this there was
something inside me where i was like i
just wanna i wanna try this one and um
and i felt i definitely felt this with
this it was like such a huge challenge
uh at a very challenging time i should
add like last summer
um you know the idea of flying to
germany uh to do this seemed mad
um but it was it was kind of the right
kind of mad um where i was like i think
you know if this
if this is the right kind of man if this
is the mad i like and i think it is then
then this could be great the thing about
this film is that it tackles and talks
about
very um issues that i believe are not so
far away because robots as we all know
are advancing every day you see videos
you're like get the hell out of here so
did you have any sort of
like change in perspective on what
robots might mean to society after
making this film because i think it asks
some really big questions
it really does um and i think you're
right that the technology is is getting
frighteningly close um
and yet i think the things that we're
frightened of
are often not the things we should be
frightened of i think you know um
there's there's all sorts of other
problems and i think what the
what the film really highlighted for me
was actually kind of reflected more back
on humanity and so it got me thinking
not so much like the
the movie doesn't lean very heavily on
the tech
um it doesn't look at the sort of you
know it's like well exactly what you
know what module are you using it like
it doesn't it doesn't really get into
the wiring or anything like that it's
much more about the
the the sort of philosophical questions
behind it and and the ideas of humanity
and also you know especially last year
the theme of loneliness seemed to
to really resonate you know um and i
guess still does that you know the idea
of
you know that perhaps one of these
things
could give somebody you know a
tremendous amount of companionship and
there's a beautiful scene
where the um the gentleman who we see at
the beginning of the movie she runs into
him in the street with his
partner and
he just gives such a i i think it really
kind of explains
the the flip side of it so beautifully
that scene and just like you know
the positives of it that we might not
even have considered and and certainly
alma hasn't really considered until that
point and um
and you know the whole the whole movie
is sort of framed around her writing up
this report and kind of analyzing this
as an experience so it's not just like
hey i've ordered this off the internet
and oh here he is and his packaging you
know off we go it's like what do you
actually what do you think about this so
we're encouraged to kind of think along
with her i think
um the whole time and uh
yeah it's it is we're on the cusp of
something where it's like it hasn't
quite happened yet
but i i love that kind of near future
sci-fi that could be like
three weeks in the future you know what
i mean and like i don't think any of us
will be surprised if in like three weeks
collider runs a piece where it's like
hey there's an android partner program
that has just been released in i don't
know career or something you're like
yeah great i totally believe that you
know
uh yeah
a hundred percent um what is the secret
for you on not blinking because i love
what i mean when you when you watch for
people that don't realize um actors are
very good at not blinking because
and i've watched so many people and they
could do like a long scene and they're
just
you know with their eyes and yeah
what's the secret for you
i have no idea i think i was also told
that it's very hard to sneeze on screen
like you can need to sneeze before you
do a scene or go on stage sometimes and
i remember like being in the wings with
an older actor once in the theater i was
like i think i need to sneeze and
they're like don't worry you'll get out
there and it just doctor theater it'll
just go away and uh and it's true like
you sort of step out there it's like oh
this my character doesn't need to sneeze
oh but did you ever practice when you
were younger about not blinking
not consciously um
uh yeah i don't know what the secret is
really um and i'm i'm sort of not even
that aware that i do i'm sure i'd blink
much more in
in regular conversation um
sure i'm gonna ask you a different
question
what can you say hypothetically about
any sort of role you may or may not have
in eternals
crow comment
wait what
wait what is that
um are you allowed to say anything or
i mean
i i said crow comment but i don't know
if that is uh cryptic enough no it was
too it was too cryptic for me and i want
to look stupid to people who are
watching no i i um
even if i could say anything i wouldn't
be able to and would have to try and
kill you through zoom
is that critical enough is that more
cryptic or less cryptic no that that's
much better i appreciate that yeah down
the road i will ask you questions um i'm
actually really excited about gaslin um
which has this crazy cast
what can you say about that
i can say a bit bit more about that one
um
yeah it's uh it's been amazing kind of
diving diving into the watergate story
um i was a huge fan of the the slowburn
podcast about about the subject and um
yeah playing john dean who um you know
those familiar with with watergate will
know will know very well but he was the
the junior council who who kind of was
the first to to turn and testify against
uh
the administration really and and to
sort of um you know
begin the uh the expose i guess um
and uh yeah and it's very much about the
the women behind those men so martha
mitchell who was in her own right a big
celebrity in in the day whose husband
john mitchell played by sean penn and
martha mitchell played by julia roberts
um
you know they were they were
they featured very largely in in this
story you know the sort of behind the
scenes story
uh as did john dean and his wife mo and
and so it really you know it looks it
you know it just it just peaks behind
the veil and you know my knowledge of
watergate was pretty surface um and uh
it's it's been amazing kind of looking
at uh
yes this sort of the roots of of
corruption
um my last thing for you um and i'll try
to be very quick uh i love learning
about actors and their process if you
were getting ready to film like a super
emotional scene on a monday how are you
getting ready for that scene beforehand
wow um it's a big question sorry yeah um
i was talking to an actor the other day
who uh used the phrase trauma harvesting
which i
which i thought was a wonderful a
wonderful description i'm not sure if i
would call it exactly that but um
i don't know it i mean it would very
much depend on the on the scene and the
scripts and the role i need i need to
know more about this frosty you can't
just you can't just throw in
a scene
you know if you've got a screenplay i
could read do you have a
character brief maybe some some image
some you know
maybe a new board
i'll do a follow-up i'll explain more
next time but um
it's basically just
i'll explain more next time but i'm
always curious if you know it's like a
week in advance if it's like a day
before you're really getting in there
you know that kind of stuff yeah i mean
it's very script specific but i think
you know generally if in that first read
you've been moved by the scene and you
know where that emotion
is coming from within the context of the
story that that helps enormously
um i don't know if that's a very good
answer to your question but there you go
totally hey listen but congrats on this
i'm i look forward to talking about some
marvel thing later
alright thanks